السيده الرئيسه اعضاء المحكمه
الموقره يشرفني ان اقف امامكم اليوم باسم
جمهوريه افريقيا جنوب افريقيا وسوف اتحدث
عن فقه
القضاء شعب جنوب
افريقيا وشعب اسرائيل عاني
من المعامله السيئه
وقع اتفاقيه منع الاباده
الجماعيه ولم يكن هناك اي اعتراض على
الماده رقم تس ولا عن عقوبات المسلطه على
جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه هذه
الاتفاقيه ترمي الى حمايه
الشعوب
منع
الاباده وهناك واجبات في هذه
الاتفاقيه وكذلك هناك واجبات على المجتمع
الدولي
ككل اعضاء هذه
الاتفاقيه عليهم ليس فقط ان لا يقوموا
ب انتهاك هذه المعاهده ولكن ايضا بان
يتصدع لمن
ينتهكها من خلال هذا العمل القان
وهذا
واضح منذ من الماده
الاولى الماده التاسعه توضح ان الدول
ينبغي ان تحمي هذه
الاتفاقيه لحمايه حقوق
الانسان وايضا تجعلها تدخل في مفاوضات و
القيام بما ينبغي القيام
به وهي ليست علاقات ثنائيه بين دوله واخرى
ولكن هي تسمح لاي دوله باسم القانون
الدولي ان تلجا
الى المحكمه المناسبه
ل التصدي
لهذا
انتهاك
افريقيا لن لم تحمل هذه القضيه الى
المحكمه مباشره كانت
تراقب مصدومه رد فعل اسرائيل على ما حدث
في السبع من
اكتوبر
و قام الاسرا يقوم الاسرائيليون
بقتل غير لا يميزون فيه
بين المدنيين وال
محاربين
و كان
هناك تصريحات عديده بان ما تقوم به
اسرائيل اصبح يرقى الى مستوى جريمه
الاباده
الجماعيه
وقد
ادن ما تقوم به ما قامت به
حماس بما في ذلك جرائم الحرب
التي تشمل ايضا جريمه
الاباده ومذكوره ايضا
في معاهده روما في الساب عشر من
اكتوبر ح قامت جنوب افريقيا بتحويل هذا
الطلب الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه من
اجل القيام بتحقيق وباعلان ذلك القرار
الرئيس
مبوزه
اشار الى فضعه ما يحدث في غزه والذي تحولت
الى سجن مغلق ترتكب فيه هذه
الجريمه جريمه الاباده الجماعيه
نطالب بان
تدان وقد اصبح من
الواضح ان هناك خلافا بين جنوب افريقيا
واسرائيل ولن ينتهي هذا الخلاف الا بتوقف
العمل العسكري لاسرائيل في
غزه في الحادي من
نوفمبر في خلال اجتماع الجمعيه العامه
للامم
المتحده ولم ياتي رد من قبل اسرائيل
وقد اوضحت اصبحت القضيه واضحه كمسه
قانونيه وقد انكرت اسرائيل في السادس من
سبتمبر
انها تقوم او ترتكب عمل اباده في
غزه وقبل تقديم هذا
الطلب جم
افريقيا صلت مع سفاره اسرائيل لتوضيح
موقفها بان ما تقوم به اسرائيل في غزه
يرقى الى مستوى الاباده الجماعيه وفيها
انتهاك لاتفاقيه
منع اباده
الجماعيه وردت
اسرائيل بطريقه لا ترد بالشكل لا ترضي
بالشكل الكامل ملاحظات
جنوب افريقيا وكان هناك تبادل للرسائل
الالكترونيه التي تلقاها الفريق المعني في
جنوب
افريقيا في الرابع من يناير ردت اسرائيل
تقول ان وهي
تعكس